a woman who killed her husband while his  friend listened over a live chat learned  her fate today emily ekuda will serve  between 10 to 25 years for killing 36  year old jarrell eng in march of 2021 a  crew was shot and killed in their  apartment while he was on a live chat  session on his computer his friend who  was on the chat heard what was happening  in the background as ing took his last  breath during the investigation several  inconsistencies surfaced between the  evidence and a cuda is a count of events  leading to her arrest and then her  guilty plea  i never expected to hear my dear  friend's last gasp over the chat line  that fatal evening  nor to be lied to by his wife over the  course of the next few days even though  she plays guilty  she has not taken accountability of the  murder of my brother  i'll always be haunted by her lives  and how come and emotionalists her voice  was when she told us  we do have all the details on this case  on our website at 8newsnow.com